hey everybody welcome to the rich roll
podcast episode 3 we thought we'd do a
little video trailer to recap what you
can expect in this episode so Julie
Pyatt my wife the star of the podcast
was a star of Episode one so we had to
bring her back right thank you
he talked about food as medicine we
talked about the word vegan we talked
about emotions behind food and a great
uniter that's right the trickiness of
the word vegan and using food to unite
people rather than divide so anyway we
hope you check it out we're having a ton
of fun doing this podcast it's been
really really cool and the early
response has been amazing I mean today I
woke up this morning and we've only done
we just I just uploaded episode two like
late last night and we were already like
number one in the fitness nutrition
category on iTunes so we're off to a
great start and we can't wait to keep
giving you great content so check it out
you can subscribe on iTunes it's on
stitcher radio and you can also go to
rich worldcom there's a podcast menu tab
click there and you can listen download
whatever so sounds good very good plant
power alright thanks